so as the series approaches its
conclusion are there any prompts on set
that you have your eye on to steal that
you're like I'm taking that there's only
one that I've ever wanted and I've I've
I've made have hinted so heavily that
the armor is and David and Dan and
everyone I want my sword and what
Longclaw and what's the response been I
mean I think the first season they went
yeah yeah yeah cause of course when we
finish this thing that's yours and as
the seasons went on and the show became
more more popular and that swords value
went up and up it becomes slow Liam
quite sure about it and that's why I'm
hinting more and more I'm like no
seriously I want that sword another yeah
I think you should straight up right I'm
not showing up at lunch straight-up
steal I'm stealing take it we're gonna
um of course the fans have been so
excited about seeing the photos of Jon
Snow and Khaleesi on the beach for you
and Amelia was that like was that like
an extra exciting day to get to finally
have that moment that you know
everyone's been wanting I can't I think
is I can't really talk about it you know
that was the most annoying thing this
season nothing is the paparazzi's
drones that were flying around I think
we've all got very upset and angry that
people would want to spoil a TV show in
that way for people so I'm not even I
know if those photos out there but I'm
not even gonna confirm whether me and
yeah or it could be a faked it could be
a setup yeah you never know what
measures were taken to preserve secrecy
I think we did everything we could
there's only there's only so much you
can do when you're filming in these
beautiful locations and you can't shut
places off and I'm so I'm so fond of it
and as it gets towards the end all these
exciting things happen which I want to
be shocks for people it really
infuriates me when I when I see someone
ruining that
you